[Musik]
hallo liebe Leute und herzlich
willkommen bei der riffa kämpft gegen
den Fachkräftemangel ich bin Larissa und
ich kämpfe gegen Fachkräftemangel warum
ganz einfach weil wir davon zu wenig
schaden also von der Fachkräften nicht
von dem Mangel weil von meine Kamera
eigentlich nicht zu wenig haben oder
weil Mangel ist ja schon Mangel
[Musik]
also du bist gerade fertig mit der
Schule dann musst du dir eine wichtige
Frage stellen willst du etwas erschaffen
mit deinen eigenen zwei Händen also
etwas Sinnvolles tun ein Handwerk oder
willst du so den einfachen Weg gehen und
vielleicht ja weiß ich nicht ein
Klugscheißer werden oder ein
Rechtsanwalt oder noch schlimmer Matte
Professor vor nein
denn davon gibt es schon mehr als genug
entscheide dich z.B lieber für den Beruf
des Anlagenmechaniker es aka das steht
für Sanitär Heizungs- und Klimatechnik
in dem Beruf fehlen nämlich 60.000
Fachkräfte klar das ist ähm ein bisschen
auch der Herr Robert Habeck Schuld daran
weil ich weiß nicht der ist eigentlich
immer schuld wenn irgendwas mit der
Heizung kaputt ist weil der hat da
irgendwann glaube ich schon mit dem
Hammer drauf gehauen habe ich mal
gezeigt und gesehen also ich bin schon
festlegen trotzdem fakt ist es gibt nur
noch halb so viele Azubis wie vor 20
Jahren warum will keiner mehr das machen
ich zeig's euch das ist voll einfach
die Kiste ist voll schwer hallo
könnten sie das freundlicherweise für
mich schämen ich habe einen Attest
habe ich wirklich
als ein Anlagenmechaniker arbeitest du
leider auch viel in so hässlichen
Häusern wie das hier ich schwöre ich
würde sterben wenn ich hier wohnen
müsste ja was ich bin nur ehrlich ich
weiß man soll ja bekanntlicherweise
keine Vorurteile haben weil die Menschen
die hier leben müssen die sind ja auch
Menschen also im weitesten Sinne und sie
brauchen Dich für Ihre Heizung dabei
kennst du nicht nur gegen die Heizung
sondern auch gegen den Klimawandel ja du
bist der Held du brauchst zum Beispiel
eine moderne Heizung ein die Gutes für
das Klima und hältst so die Aufwärmung
auf also nicht die Heizung die macht ja
erstmal wärmer aber du brauchst ja auch
viele Klimaanlagen ein und die machen
mit kälter und so ist alles wieder im
natürlichen Gleichgewicht Kreislauf
sag mal machst du immer noch Pause ja
meine Güte hetz mich nicht ich bin
Fachkraft Gottes
sie haben es wirklich sehr gemütlich
hier
das ist ein Rohrzange das sind
Schraubenschlüssel das ist ein
Nussknacker was viele nicht wissen die
Heizung steht sehr oft im Keller also
arbeitest du auch viel im Keller und der
Keller befindet sich unter der Erde da
ist es erstens immer schön kühl vor
allem im Sommer die Ausbildung dauert
ungefähr dreieinhalb Jahre weil es gibt
auch wirklich viel zu lernen allein die
verschiedenen Arten von Heizung Öl Gas
Wärmepumpe und Lagerfeuer da muss man
sich schon sehr gut auskennen leider
gibt es immer noch zu wenig Frauen die
diesen Beruf ergreifen und ich schreib
mich wirklich warum ich verstehe es
nicht Schwestern Girls die Zeit ist reif
für starke Frauen die Männerberufe
stürmen und viele sagen jetzt bestimmt
so aber nein ich bin ja nicht Technik
und so falsch da ist immer noch das alte
meins hätte nur im Kopf drin wir können
das auch so Rohren und so
ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf ich
schaffe das ich kann das wenn ihr mich
über die Schulter guckt dann kann ich
nicht arbeiten das ist Mens planning
lass das ich glaube ich weiß warum ich
das nicht hinkriege ich habe Vitamin D
Mangel ich bin nicht die ganze Zeit
unter der Erde im Keller und hier
scheint keine Sonne vitamin D ist
nämlich richtig für das Immunsystem das
kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren ich
muss raus an die frische Luft hier nimm
das bitte mal wirklich ich liebe dich
aus also das Problem ist wie immer auch
ein demografischen Wandel mehr Menschen
gehen in Rente als gleichzeitig junge
Menschen nachwachsen und für die Rentner
muss dann ja alles modernisiert werden
weil alte Leute können ja nicht mehr so
gut springen und klettern und deswegen
brauchen Sie zum Beispiel ein Badezimmer
das frei von Barrieren ist ja weil sie
sich waschen können oder meine Güte die
Vorstellung
[Musik]
ja und hier seht ihr der Beruf ist nicht
mehr mit früher vergleichbar damals
nannte man den Beruf ja
umgangssprachlich das Wasser Scheiße
mittlerweile ist allerdings auch sehr
viel Computer Wasser scheiße
also werdet Anlagenmechaniker sakk denn
das ist für uns alle das Beste alles was
ihr dafür braucht ist eine solche
Latzhose diese heißt Blaumann auch wenn
man eine Frau ist ich denke mal wegen
gender das Beste ist weil es viel zu
wenig Anlagenmechaniker gibt seid ihr
sowas wie Popstars ich schwöre ihr seid
immer ausgebucht alle wollen euch haben
das ist voll gemacht geht das fühlt sich
voll gut an wenn man den Kunden so sagen
kann ja okay wir kommen dann vielleicht
in den nächsten Monaten zwischen 6 Uhr
und 18 Uhr sehen Sie bitte zu Hause voll
der Boss move das einzige was ich
persönlich etwas bedenklich finde ist
dass man teilweise wirklich sehr früh
aufstehen muss manchmal sogar um 6 Uhr
vielleicht wäre hier Home Office eine
Alternative denkt aber darüber nach also
mach's gut eure Larissa
[Musik]